du vin bio des bières artisanales de la
confiture maison et même du safran le
domaine de candie était une nouvelle
fois le lieu de rendez-vous des
gourmands à l'occasion du marché du même
nom une trentaine d'exposants présents
et nombre de curieux ou de gastronomes
venus avant tout pour se faire plaisir
et savourer de bons produits on a goûté
à tout ce qu'on n'a pas le droit de
goûter moi j'ai tué le cholestérol
ma femme est à côté a même pas engueulé
parce que j'ai pris
il est délicieux et s'éteint c'est un
moment de plaisir servant de vie et sur
l'un des stands consacrés au miel dans
tous ses états à l'img aviez apiculteurs
artane depuis 1989 développe quantité de
produits dérivés de ce très bon hectares
il est propriétaire de 70 ruches et
depuis près de 20 ans cet ancien
pâtissier à la retraite a su diversifier
sa production fait des nougats je fais
des anneaux gâté feu des bombes ont fait
chuter nos net je fais des galettes
galette sable et au miel des croquants
des palais pays je fais plein de choses
à base de miel et produits ont de plus
en plus à quoi toi un peu plus loin
c'est le safran qui attire les curieux
le safran duval un produit 400 g par an
et fait partie des safraniers de
touraine qui compte une trentaine
d'adhérents sur le département pour une
production d'un peu moins de 4 kg par an
il faut savoir qu'il faut pas moins de
150 fleurs pour récolter un gramme de
safran cette épice qui malgré les idées
reçues peut se cuisiner pour 1 à 2 euros
par plat et apporte une petite saveur
délicate subtil c'est plus dans la
subtilité le safran il ne ressemble à
rien d'autre
et il est complètement à part il donne
une couleur aussi assez chatoyantes
jaune au plat
donc voilà il ravive à la fois les yeux
le palais et le dorat et pour raviver
tous ces plaisirs le domaine de candé
propose tout l'été de nombreuses
animations gastronomiques
le dernier marché gourmand de la saison
aura lieu le 23 septembre